the countdown is on as Kathie Lee
Gifford prepares for her exit from the
Today Show I consider Mota one my
dearest dearest forever she's crying
already
the tears will really be flowing next
Friday April 5th Kathie Lee's last day
on the job
what's the thing you're gonna miss most
about her the day that I met Kat I feel
like everything changed and got better
and got happier her first day was back
in 2008 we were there for that too she
cried and then she said please tell me
you're gonna cook at me we have so much
fun Wow it was all Hoda
it was all Hoda and then I just fell in
love with her then came you then came
you these two went through a lot
together in 11 years including the death
of Kathie Lee's husband Frank Gifford in
2015 Frank is here in spirit oh no what
did he think about this motley it was it
was Frank who said you got to do it yeah
he said she's wonderful and you guys are
gonna be great together and he was right
listen to this speed round how many
glasses of wine have you two had over
the past 11 years - 11 3 total c-5 what
that's our story and we're sticking to
it how many interviews have you
conducted wild tipsy oh wow Lucy 3 well
today was tipsy Tuesday so I had to join
in
[Music]